We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. a very good question.
And really more of a comment raising an important
issue about conservatives and the military
in today's voicemail.
Take a listen.
Hi David.
It's Sue calling from Idaho.
I love your, you know, that interviewed Trump
did with Hannity and throwing, um, Biden's
son under the bus about his Naval career and
Trump avoiding the draft.
Did anyone else see the hypocrisy of that?
That that just made me want to vomit.
So keep up the good work and, uh, I don't
do Instagram or any of that kind of social
media.
So that's why I'm calling you and letting
you know that, that, that, that hypocrisy
needs to be brought out and remind people
he avoided the draft.
He's got no business talking about anybody
else's, um, military career.
Yeah.
Listen, there's actually, there's two, so,
okay.
Hypocrisy.
Number one is specific to Trump, which is
Trump criticizes other people and what they
do or don't do with regard to the military
where Trump got this letter signed by a doctor
about his bone spurs in his ankle is a very
strong letter on the ankles, is Donald Trump
on set who talks that way, by the way?
Um, and it's bogus, but I have to tell you,
I would have done anything possible not to
be drafted to Vietnam.
It was a ridiculous war.
It was a disaster.
And I understand why people would try to get
out of it now for Trump, it was, he wouldn't
go to any war.
He was the rich kid who wanted a doctor's
note.
And I totally get that.
But I actually don't really criticize people
for finding ways out of the Vietnam war on
principle.
That actually makes sense to me.
Although he is a hypocrite.
The real hypocrisy is that the Rite frames
itself as Uber respectful and, and sort of
honoring the military careers of everybody
except when it's people on the left and the
or, and not even people on the left, even
sometimes just people they disagree with.
If you look at what they did to John Kerry
in 2004, um, what happened to respect for
people who served in the military instead
attacking John Kerry's, um, uh, participation
in the Vietnam war.
Look at Trump going after John McCain, the
late Senator from Arizona, John McCain, where
he said everything from, I prefer war heroes
who don't get captured to who knows what else.
Look at how they go after whoever, right?
That is the real hypocrisy that the right
claims to have a monopoly or the moral high
ground on respecting and honoring the service
of military members when in reality it's only
a tool to, it's a proxy to demonstrate their
patriotism, but it disappears as soon as someone's
in the military that they don't like, whether
it was pea Buddha, judge or whoever it is
that they want to criticize.
All of a sudden the military service respect
goes out the window.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Two ways to get access, become a member or
become a patron.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].